this season on Lauren and Alexi after
the 90 days are you shy
who's having more fun Abba or shy come
on shy do I get a haircut I might cry
I'm not ready
dad do you want to model
yes thank you I'm biased but I think
we've got some very cute kids leave me
and my boys out of it no not the boys I
mean look at those faces
let me ask you a question after I have
this baby do you recommend a vasectomy
for Alex he definitely thinks that Alex
should get a vasectomy no he doesn't no
man thinks that oh snip snip
cool it's getting real like we're going
to Israel as a family this is not a
vacation this is not a trip it's an
experience
[Music]
Scott this is the first time since our
Israeli wedding that my parents and her
parents and everybody are there together
[Music]
they've built a great life
how do you just give that up well I keep
hearing about is a possible move to
Israel enough is enough there's no way
that I'm ever going to support this
before you speak to an attorney I want
to know who legally has the right to
those children me and Lauren are not
going to a divorce attorney so then
we're done here you said to them I don't
think she's capable of living here
that's not what I did I heard it she's
tried to control me my whole life and
she hates that she's lost control shut
the up whoa we're done enjoy your trip
in insane
[Music]